[Musica]
buonasera a tutti mi chiamo football sei
sono cinesina e da tre anni abito in
sardegna a cagliari dove sono arrivata
grazie al progetto forumed il progetto
finanziato dalla fondazione di sardegna
che ha permesso a me ea tanti ragazzi
dell'area mediterranea divenire
associare laurea magistrale anche tre
annale all'università degli studi di
cagliari
stavo per finire la laurea magistrale
all'istituto superiore di commercio di
biserta in studi bancari finanziari in
tunisia
mi mancava solamente di sostenere la
tesi ed ero in cerca di nuove
opportunità
una sera stavo pagando col mio pc su
internet
controllando le notizie dell'università
cercavo proprio una borsa di studio per
andare a studiare all'estero
ho sempre parlato nella mia vita
quotidiana sia la vostra francese ma già
dal liceo avevo un desiderio imparare
l'italiano
mio fratello bashir ha vissuto tanti
anni in germania
mio zio mohammed aveva deciso di partire
con sé di portarlo a frank fori sul mano
con la moglie maria d'origine italiana
dopo essere stati parecchi anni in
germania decisero di tornare in tunisia
di vivere e lavorare molti anni molti
chilometri ci avevamo diviso ma
soprattutto una cosa che non avevamo più
in comune la lingua
quando dunque al liceo dovete decidere
chi lingua studiare sensi l'italiano
come vi ho raccontato prima stavo per
finire la laurea magistrale
sono stata accettata a compim
come tutti conoscete complesse e la
piattaforma online la procedura di
ammissione all'università francese sono
stata messa a fare il secondo anno di
laurea magistrale a hickson cross in
studi finanziari e bancari
quindi mi trattavo di lasciare la mia
famiglia e rischiavo di non avere
senza soldi per poter sostenere il mio
percorso di studio quindi stavo cercando
altre opportunità di finanziamento e
così ho scoperto format quello che mi
offriva forme era la possibilità di
seguire un intero corso di studio
completamento incarico dall
organizzazione e avere una borsa di
studio non solo di pagare l'affitto ma
anche di vivere dignitosamente
quindi inoltre potevo finalmente
imparare l'italiano e parlare bene col
mio fratello bashir non ero mai stata in
italia però la mia zia maria diceva è
sempre chi bella l'italia
quanto mi manca mio padre era un
ospedale
era agosto c'erano 45 gradi in tunisia
ricevette una lettera dall'ambasciata
italiana in tunisia mi comunicava che
sono stata accettata
ho detto subito alla mia mamma cha che
mi ha detto immediatamente vai
questa è una grande opportunità per il
tuo futuro potrei lavorare e studiare
all'estero in italia quindi ho deciso di
non partire
in francia è di finire a cagliari ha
avuto solo una settimana per preparare i
bagagli nel mentre facevo un corso
intensivo di italiano al centro
linguistico italiano in tunisia e sono
venuta il 9 settembre 2015
qui nel capoluogo sardo non parlavo bene
l'italiano fortunatamente ad attendermi
gli altri ragazzi selezionate c'era un
tutor che ci ha aiutato a ambientarci
cercare una stanza capire bene il
funzionamento dell'università
eravamo la prima edizione del progetto
format era tutto nuovo
sia per loro che per noi il mio corso di
studio era
molto internazionale c'erano solo se
ragazzi italiani inizialmente quindi ho
fatto amicizia solo con i ragazzi
erasmus ed al progetto forumed cagliari
è una città molto tranquilla risposta
rispetto cartage più mi sono potuta con
centrale allo studio a tempo pieno
il primo semestre non sono riuscita a
passare neanche un esame il sistema
universitario e la tipologia di
apprendimento sono completamento diverso
nel mio corso di studio in tunisia si
occupavano soprattutto dalle
applicazioni pratiche dello studio nel
pensiero bancario invece qui
occorreva soprattutto di memorizzare
tantissimi nozioni ed aprile sono
tornata sono tornata in tunisia per
sostenere la tesi di laurea
mio padre stava bene
abbiamo festeggiato ma al mio ritorno a
cagliari ho scoperto se non avessi
passato 30 crediti sarei stata esclusa
dal progetto invece all'inizio del mese
di luglio ero riuscita a passare 42
crediti anche la mia responsabile era
molto contenta il secondo anno è stato
più semplici per me ho deciso di partire
in erasmus di andare in germania dove ho
anche svolto un tirocinio presso una
importante agenzia americana che si
occupa nel settore aerospaziale
sono stata ammessa
al mese di film di mese di febbraio
comunque mia al dicembre 2016
c'è un ragazzo tunisino che aveva fatto
un attestato a berlino mi comunicava
l'azienda mi ha detto jorg in passport
sposa con italiano e poi venire alla
fine mi sono stata accettata
grazie alla raccomandazione a chi mia ho
finito la mia responsabile del progetto
in questo momento quando sono rientrata
a cagliari
mi sono sentita come se fosse in tunisia
in questo momento io sono accettata a a
fare il corso di dottorato in economia
in storia anche sono accettate a fare un
master di alti studi europeo al collegio
europeo di parma
pensavo che è una opportunità di
continuare il mio percorso di studio
prima della rivoluzione
un euro corrispondeva a 2,1 dina dopo la
rivoluzione in tunisia un euro
l'inflazione è cresciuta
esponenzialmente quindi un euro
corrispondeva a 3,4 dinar quindi tutti i
giovani tunisini pensano esclusivamente
a negrar e tutti i miei sorelli studiano
all'università e adesso
consiglierei a tutti i miei sorelle di
vivere questa esperienza la sardegna
l'isola del sole mi ha permesso di
credere allo studio
ringrazio la mia famiglia che mi ha
permesso che ha sempre creduto dello
studio le possibilità
la min cicatrice che lo studio offre
anche ai giovani magrebini e grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]